(upbeat music)
- We are picky eaters
and we are going to play
would you rather.
- I have very strong
conviction when it comes
to my dining experience.
There's things I like
and things I don't like.
- I hate cilantro and I hate ginger
and if the seasonings are off to me
it'll just come right back out.
- I don't think there's going
to be a lot of good choices
ahead for us.
So there's probably just
going to be a lot of tears.
- All right you ready?
- Yeah.
- Would you rather eat beats
or eat brussels sprouts?
Easy for me brussels sprouts.
Clear winner, I'm all right with that.
- Really?
- Ugh, that's gross.
- Both.
- No, not at all.
I've never had a beat
never will eat a beat.
So I will eat the green appetizer.
- Why won't you eat a beat?
- I don't believe in it.
- I think I have to go with beats.
Assuming it's a cooked beat,
because they're kind of
soft and a little bit slimy.
- I would also eat brussels sprouts,
especially roasted brussels sprouts.
- Would you rather eat
a spoonful of mayonnaise
or a spoonful of ketchup?
- That's just so gross.
I can't do either.
Either would gross me out.
- Ketchup, no question.
I find mayonnaise revolting.
I never want it on my sandwiches ever.
- Basically like french
fries, chicken nuggets,
chicken tenders they're
just ketchup delivery tools.
They're just a way to
get more ketchup into me.
So I'd say a spoonful of ketchup.
- I guess I'll take
you're spoon of mayonnaise
because I freaking love mayonnaise.
- I guess I'll do ketchup over mayonnaise.
I do like ranch though.
- I love ranch, oh yeah.
- Ranch is fantastic.
- A spoonful of ranch, I'll
take a shot of ranch right now.
- Would you rather bite
into a whole raw onion,
or bite into a whole raw bell pepper?
- Ugh, okay, all right, so
I will literally throw up
if I eat onions.
One time it was high school,
I had a sandwich and I
said no onions lunch lady
and sure as hell there's onions in there
I threw up my sandwich because
of onions in that sandwich.
What was the second option?
- Bell peppers.
- Take that over onion
any day of the week.
- I would rather eat the raw bell pepper.
Because it can be kind of sweet
but an onion, like ew,
I can't even cut that
without crying so why would I eat that.
- I cannot eat bell peppers.
It liquefies everything
in my body immediately.
- I love how it's a beautiful thing
where I vomit in one direction,
you vomit in the other one.
That's kind of this beautiful
symbiotic relationship.
- This was a perfect storm.
- Bell pepper all the way.
Like onions are my number
one most hated thing.
Can you just bite into an onion?
- I feel like it would flake off on you.
- Yeah, and they're like hard and weird.
- No.
- Would you rather eat a
spoonful of cottage cheese
or a spoonful of blue cheese?
- I actually love cottage cheese.
- I also love cottage cheese.
- Whoa, almost no one does.
- I know, I feel like we're not as picky
as we thought we were.
- Cottage cheese.
Blue cheese is just kind of gross.
- I don't like to eat anything
that smells like feet.
I mean that's my overall rule.
- You don't like to eat anything,
is your overall rule.
- Yeah.
- Would you rather eat
sushi or eat raw oysters?
Eat sushi.
- Sushi all day every day.
- Sushi of course.
- An oyster just looks like a snot to me.
- Yeah.
- So I can't.
- I'm a big texture guy
so I've had amazing oyster in the past,
and they've tasted okay,
but at the end of the
day it's that goopiness
that I can't do.
- I don't love sushi,
but I'll eat it in a pinch.
Like if that's what everyone wants to have
I'm like, "Okay."
- All right, would you rather
eat a bunch of broccoli
or eat a bunch of cilantro?
- I think I'd have to go with broccoli,
but I mean is it cooked
and covered in cheese?
- I think they mean raw broccoli.
- Broccoli we've already solved that.
I ate a bunch of broccoli last night.
- Cilantro is bad.
Like it is soap flavored paper.
- It's garbage, I hate cilantro.
Everyone who says
cilantro is good is lying.
- They are.
- I also would go with broccoli.
- I love broccoli.
Can't get enough of it.
It's really easy, it's how
I build a balance diet.
So I'll have a 10 piece of chicken wings
and I'll just have a handful of broccoli.
- Would you rather eat
potato salad or egg salad?
- Oh god.
- I guess I would go with the egg salad
because I like my potatoes warm.
- I don't like eggs in that fashion.
If it's not hot and cooked.
- You don't like hard boiled eggs?
- Oh god no.
- I'm also going to go with egg.
- All right.
- Egg salad.
- I'm team potato salad.
- I guess I'm team potato salad.
I've probably had maybe five
bites of either of these ever.
- Would you rather eat a bowl of peas
or a bowl of beans?
- Peas, I love peas.
People don't like peas.
I didn't know that, that's new.
I love peas.
- I think I'm going to go with beans
because they're the closest to meat.
- That makes sense.
I'm also going to go with beans.
- There's certain Chinese restaurants
and they put peas in their fried rice
and I always have to pick the peas out.
I don't know, I'm not a pea fan.
- Oh, would you rather
eat pineapple on a pizza
or eat olives on a pizza?
Olive pizza all the way.
I love olives.
- Oh god.
- Oh man.
- I love pineapple, that being said
I don't think it belongs on a pizza.
- I'd rather bite into
a stupid pineapple pizza
versus an olive pizza.
- Interesting.
- I hate olives, I can't do it.
- Also not a fan of olives
that would ruin the pizza
for me just as much.
So I'm going to eat the
pineapple on the pizza
and maybe secretly pick off the pineapple
and eat that first.
- I'm much more of a Hawaiian pizza guy.
And I like the pineapple on it.
You know what would make
a great pizza I think,
it's like a vegetarian, Hawaiian pizza.
If you just put pineapple
and olives on it.
I think that would be a good combination.
- Disgusting.
- Would you rather eat a
spoonful of steat tartare
or a spoonful of caviar?
- Steak tartare is great.
Just raw really nice cow meat.
- I think I would go
with the steak tartare.
- What the hell is that?
- That's like basically just raw beef.
- Is that all it is, just raw.
- Yeah, and then you sort
of mix it up with egg yolks
and there's like capers and
some other stuff in there,
but that's it.
It's delicious, it's one
of my favorite appetizers
at a fancy dinner.
- Okay, so I will go with the caviar.
- Fish eggs huh?
- Yeah, I'd rather go with fish eggs.
- Caviar is just like kind
of briny and gross anyways.
- Yeah, I've never had either
to be completely honest.
The steak tartare literally
just made me hungry right now.
So I feel like I would go steak.
- It's like eat raw,
you know when you buy hamburger meat
from the grocery store and you're like,
"Mm, that looks pretty good as is.
"I know I should cook it."
- What, that's so gross.
- You don't think that?
- It looks like brains.
- Yeah it looks pretty good.
- I'd be down with some steak tartare.
- Steak tartare is great.
- I think I'm not as
picky as I thought I was.
- It seems like you're dislikes
are very specific.
And you could easily avoid them.
Where mine seem to be at every meal ever.
- It kind of shows the different levels
of picky eaters I guess,
because we clash on many of things.
- I liked mayonnaise.
- And you're wrong.
- So these were our choices,
but we're wondering what would
your choices be in the comments.
(upbeat music)